[MUSIC PLAYING]
Mr. Churchill will be
introduced by the American elder
statesman, Bernard Baruch.
The program will be opened
by Dr. Karl T. Compton,
but before that, the national
anthem is being played.
Dr. Compton is chairman
of the Corporation of MIT.
[NATIONAL ANTHEM PLAYING]
Ladies and gentlemen,
Dr. Karl T. Compton.
Mr. Churchill, Mr. Baruch,
distinguished guests, ladies
and gentlemen.
May I first read the
following excerpt
from a letter received from the
White House, dated March 25th.
My dear Dr. Compton,
I certainly regret
exceedingly that conditions
developed to the point
where I had to make a
cancellation at the last minute
for the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology appearance.
I hope you will express
my sincere regret
to the members of the
faculty of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology and
make it perfectly clear to them
that the cancellation
was not a voluntary one,
but was a case of necessity.
I had a most pleasant evening
with the former prime minister
of Great Britain.
Mr. Churchill, I am
sure, will give you
something that will be
historical for this period.
Signed, Harry S. Truman.
[APPLAUSE]
And now to introduce our
very distinguished guest
from overseas, I shall
call upon his old friend,
a very distinguished American.
With deep feelings of
respect and affection,
he is called chief
by all of those
who have had the rare
privilege of working under him.
Those who have not had
this privilege also
admire him for his great
wisdom, high integrity,
and unswerving devotion to
the welfare of our country.
The advisor to presidents,
America's elder statesman,
Mr. Bernard M. Baruch.
[APPLAUSE]
Mr. Churchill,
ladies and gentlemen.
Last Sunday, from the
windows of my house,
we watched a parade
celebrating the anniversary
of Greek independence.
Men, women, and
toddling children
marched through cheering crowds,
composed of all races, creeds,
and colors.
The man who honors us tonight
turned suddenly to me and said
with deep emotion, you see,
you cannot quench freedom.
That thought is
the driving force
of this peace-hungering
man who feels so deeply
for those who suffer the blood,
sweat, and tears of life.
With a deep sympathy
for the unfortunate,
he has a daring
contempt for the bully.
Through the 30
years I have known
him, in his darkest
moments, although always
mindful of his
country's welfare,
I have never known him to
make an ignoble proposal.
I present the greatest
living Englishman,
the finest flowering of
leadership and statesmanship
that England ever produced,
the right honorable Winston
Churchill.
[APPLAUSE]
Dr. Compton, your excellency,
ladies and gentlemen,
I am honored by your wish
that I should take part
in the discussions
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
We have suffered
in Great Britain
by the lack of colleges
of university rank
in which engineering and the
allied subjects are taught.
Industrial production
depends on technology,
and it is because the Americans,
like the pre-war Germans,
have realized this and created
institutions for the advanced
training of large numbers
of high-grade engineers
to translate the advantages of
pure science into industrial
technique--
it is for that reason
that their output
per head and constant
standard of life are so high.
It is surprising that England,
which was the first country
to be industrialized, has
nothing of comparable stature.
If tonight, I strike
other notes than those
of material progress,
it implies no
want of admiration for
all the work you have done
and are doing.
My aim, like yours,
is to be guided
by balance and proportions.
The outstanding feature
of the 20th century
has been the enormous
expansion in the numbers who
are given the
opportunity to share
in the larger and more varied
life, which in previous periods
was reserved for the few
and for the very few.
This process must continue
at an increasing rate.
If we are bring
the broad message
of the people in every land
to the table of abundance,
it can only be by the tireless
improvement of all our means
of technical production
and by the diffusion
in every form of education
of an improved quality
to scores of millions
of men and women.
Even in this darkening
hour, I have faith
that this process will go on.
I rejoice in Tennyson's
celebrated lines--
men, my brothers,
men, the workers,
ever reaping something
new, that which
they have done but earnest of
the things that they shall do.
I was, however, a
little disquieted,
I must admit, that you
found it necessary to debate
the question, to quote Dr.
[? Bertrad's ?] opening
address, of whether the
problem of world production,
yielding at least a minimum
living to the whole population,
can be solved and whether
man has so destroyed
the resources of his
world that they may
be doomed to die of starvation.
If, with all resources
of modern science,
we find ourselves unable
to avert world famine,
we shall all be to blame.
But a peculiar responsibility
would rest upon the scientists.
I do not believe that they
will fail, but if they do--
or perhaps were not
allowed to succeed--
the consequences would
be very unpleasant,
because it is quite certain
that mankind would not
agree to starve equally.
And there might be some
very sharp disagreements
about how the last
crust was to be shared.
[LAUGHTER]
As our greatest
intellectual authorities
here will readily admit, that
would simplify our problem
in an unduly primordial manner.
[LAUGHTER]
Ladies and gentlemen,
I frankly confess
that I feel somewhat
overawed in addressing
this vast scientific and learned
audience on the subjects which
your panels are discussing.
I have no technical and
no university education.
I have just had to pick up a
few things as I went along.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
Therefore, I speak
with a diffidence,
which I hope to
overcome as I proceed,
on these profound scientific,
social, and philosophic issues,
each of which [INAUDIBLE] a
life-long study for itself
and are now to be examined,
as school men would say,
not only in their integrity,
but in their relationships,
meaning thereby not only
one-by-one, but all together.
I was so glad that in
the first instance,
you asked me to
talk about the past,
rather than to peer
into the future,
because I know
more about the past
than I do about the future.
And I was well content that the
President of the United States,
whose gift of prophesy
was so remarkably
vindicated by recent
electoral results--
[APPLAUSE]
--though shouldn't have
accepted that cost.
We all regret that his heavy
state duties prevent him
from being there tonight.
I shall therefore have to try
to do a little of the peering
myself.
Ladies and gentleman,
for us in Britain,
the 19th century ended amid the
glories of the Victorian era,
and we entered upon the dawn
of the 20th in high hope
for our country, our
empire, and the world.
The
Latter and larger part
of the 19th century
had been the period
of liberal advance--
liberal with a small
L. In 1900, a sense
of moving hopefully forward to
brighter, broader, and easier
days was predominant.
Little did we guess that
what is being called
the century of the
common man would witness
as its outstanding feature
more common men killing
each other with greater
facilities than any other five
centuries put together in
the history of the world.
But we entered this terrible
20th century with confidence.
We thought that with
improving transportation,
nations would get to
know each other better.
We believed that as they got
to know each other better,
they would like each other more,
and that national rivalries
would fade in a growing
international consciousness.
We took it almost for granted
that science would confer
continued [? boons ?]
and blessings upon us,
would give us better meals,
better garments, and better
dwellings for less trouble,
and thus steadily shorten
the hours of labor and leave
more time for play and culture.
In the name of ordered
but unceasing progress,
we saluted the age of democracy,
democracy expressing itself
ever more widely
through parliaments
freely and fairly elected on a
broad or universal franchise.
We saw no reason then why
men and women should not
shape their own home life and
careers without being cramped
by the growing complexity
of the state, which
was to be their servant and
the protector or their rights.
You had the famous
American maxim--
governments derive
their just powers
from the consent
of the governed.
And we both noticed
that the world
was divided into peoples
that owned the governments
and governments that
owned the peoples.
At least I heard all
this around that time,
and I liked some
of it very much.
[INAUDIBLE] minister in the
British Liberal government--
with a large L,
please, this time--
returned by a great
majority in 1906.
That new liberal
government arrived in power
with much of its message already
delivered and most of it's aims
already achieved.
The days of hereditary
aristocratic privilege
were ended or numbered.
The path was open for talent
in every field of endeavor.
Primary education was
compulsory, universal,
and free--
or about to become so.
New problems,
arising as problems
due from former successes,
awaited the new administration.
The independence of
the [? proletarium, ?]
the independence of
the proletariat from
[? thralldom ?] involved
at least a minimum standard
of life and labor and security
for old age, sickness,
and the death of the
family breadwinner.
It was to these costs of social
reform and social insurance
that we addressed ourselves.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the name of Lloyd George
will never be associated
in Great Britain
with its new departure.
I am proud to have been its
lieutenant in this work,
and also later as a conservative
chancellor of the [INAUDIBLE],,
and later still as head of the
wartime national coalition,
to have carried these
same themes forward
on a magnified scale.
That's how we began the century.
Science presently placed
novel and dangerous facilities
in the hands of the
most powerful countries.
[INAUDIBLE] humanity
was informed
that it could make
machines that would
fly through the air
and vessels which
could swim beneath the
surface of the seas.
The conquest of the air and the
perfection of the art of flying
fulfilled the dream which
for thousands of years
had glittered in
human imagination.
Certainly, it was a
marvelous and romantic event.
Whether the bestowal
of this gift
upon an immature civilization,
composed of competing nations
whose nationalism grew with
every advance of democracy,
and who was yet devoid of
international organization--
whether this gift was
a blessing or a curse
has yet to be proved.
On the whole, I
remain an optimist.
For good or for ill, air mastery
is today the supreme expression
of military power.
And fleets and armies,
however vital and important,
must accept a subordinate rank.
This is a memorable milestone
in the march of man.
The submarine could
do it justice.
I've never made any claim
to be a blessing or even
a convenience.
I well remember when it
became an accomplished fact
of peculiar military
significance
to the British Isles
and to the British Navy.
There was a general belief,
even in the admiral [INAUDIBLE],,
where I presided, that
no nation would ever
be so wicked as to use these
underwater vessels to sink
merchantmen at sea.
How could a submarine,
it was asked,
provide for the safety of
the crews, of the merchant
ships it sank?
And public opinion was shocked
when old Admiral Fisher bluntly
declared that this would be
no bar to the submarine's
being used by the new and
growing German Navy in the most
ruthless manner.
His prediction was
certainly not stultified
by what was soon to happen.
Here then we have
these two novel
and potent weapons
placed in the hands
of highly nationalized,
sovereign states
in the early part
of the 20th century.
And both of them
dwell with us today
for our future edification.
A third unmeasured
sphere opened to us
as the years passed,
which for the sake
of comprehensive brevity
I will describe as radar.
This radar, with its innumerable
variance in possibilities,
had so far been the
handmaiden of the air.
But it has also been the
enemy of the submarine,
and in alliance with the air
may well prove its exterminator.
Thus, we see the changes which
were brought upon our society.
In the first half
of the 20th century,
and by the crimson wings of
war, the conquest of the air
affected profoundly
human affairs.
It made the globe seem
much bigger to the mind
and much smaller to the body.
The human biped was able to
travel about far more quickly.
This greatly reduced
the size of his estate,
while at the same time
creating an even keener sense
of its exploitable value.
In the 19th century, Jules
Verne wrote Around the World
in 80 Days.
It seemed a prodigy.
Now you can get
round it in four,
but you do not see
much of it on your way.
[LAUGHTER]
The whole prospect
and outlook of mankind
grew really immeasurably larger,
and the multiplication of ideas
also proceeded at
an incredible rate.
This vast expansion
was unhappily not
accompanied by any noticeable
advance in the stature of man,
either in his mental faculties
or his moral character.
His brain got no better,
but it bounced the more.
[? Though ?] the scale
of events around him
assumed gigantic
proportions while he
remained about the same size.
By comparison, therefore, he
actually became much smaller.
We no longer had great men
directing manageable affairs.
Our need was the discipline and
array of gigantic and turbulent
[? fact. ?] To this
task, we have certainly
so far proved unequal.
Science bestowed immense new
powers, and at the same time
created conditions
which were largely
beyond its comprehension, and
still more beyond its control.
While he nursed the
illusion of growing mastery
and exulted his
new trappings, he
became the sport, and
presently the victim,
of tides and currents, or
whirlpools and tornadoes,
amid which he was far
more helpless than he
had been for a long time.
Hopeful developments
in many directions
were proceeding in 1914 on
both sides of the Atlantic,
and they seemed to point to
an age of peace and plenty,
when suddenly violent
events broke in upon them.
For more than 20
years, there had
been no major war in Europe.
Indeed, since the Civil
War in the United States,
there had been no great
struggle in the West.
A spirit of adventure
stirred the minds of men
and was by no means allayed
by the general advance
of prosperity and science.
On the contrary,
prosperity meant power,
and science offered weapons.
We read in the Bible--
I hope you still
read the Bible--
Jeshurun waxed fat and kicked.
For several
generations, Britannia
had ruled the waves for
long periods at less cost
annually than that of a
single modern battleship.
History, I think,
ladies and gentlemen--
history will say that this
great trust was not abused.
American testimony about the
early period of the Monroe
Doctrine is upon records.
That was the suppression of the
slave trade [? embarrassing. ?]
During our prolonged
Naval supremacy,
undeterred by the rise
of foreign [INAUDIBLE],,
we kept our ports freely open
to the commerce of the world.
Our colonial and oriental
empire, even our coastal trade,
was free to the shipping of
all the nations on equal terms.
We in no way sought to obstruct
the right of other states
or navies.
For nearly the whole
of the 19th century,
the monopoly of sea
power in British hands
was a trust
discharged faithfully
in the general interest.
[APPLAUSE]
But in the first decade
of the 20th century,
with new patterns of
warships, naval rivalries
became acute and fierce.
Civilized governments began
to think in dreadnoughts.
It was in such a setting
[INAUDIBLE] to prevent
the First World War--
far more difficult
than it would have been
to have prevented the second.
There was, of course,
one way to prevent it,
one way then as now--
the creation of an international
instrument strong enough
to adjust the
disputes of nations
and enforce its decisions
against an aggressor.
Much wisdom, eloquence,
and earnest effort
was devoted to this theme in
which the United States took
the lead, but we only got as far
as the World Court at the Hague
and improvements in
the Geneva Convention.
The impulses towards a
trial of strength in Europe
were far stronger at this time.
Germany demanding
her place in the sun
was faced by a resolute
France with a military honor
to regain.
England, in accordance with our
foreign policy of 300 years,
sustained the weak outside.
France found an ally in
the Russia of the czars,
and Germany in the crumbling
empire of the Habsburgs.
The United States,
for reasons which
were natural and
traditional, but no longer so
[? varied ?] as in
the past, stood aloof
and expected to be able
to watch as a spectator
the thrilling, fearful drama
unfold from across what was
then called the broad Atlantic.
Though these expectations,
as you perhaps may remember,
were not wholly borne
out by what happened.
After four years of hideous
mechanical slaughter,
illuminated by
infinite sacrifice,
but not remarkably relieved
by strategy or generalship,
the victorious Allies
assembled at Versailles.
High hopes and spacious
opportunities awaited them.
War stripped of
every pretension,
of glamor or romance,
had been brought home
to the masses of the peoples,
and brought home in forms
never before experienced,
except by the defeated.
To stop another war was
the supreme object and duty
of the statesmen who met
as friends and allies
around the peace table.
They made great errors.
The doctrine of
self-determination
was not the remedy
for Europe, which
needed then, above all things,
unity and larger groupings.
The idea that the
vanquished could
pay the expenses of the victors
was a destructive and crazy
delusion.
The failure to strangle
Bolshevism at its birth
and to bring Russia,
then prostrate,
by one means or another into
the general democratic system
lies heavy upon us today.
Nevertheless, the
statesmen at Versailles,
largely at the inspiration
of President Wilson,
an inspiration implemented
effectively by British thought,
created the League of Nations.
This is our defense
before history,
and had the league been
resolutely sustained and used,
it would have saved us all.
This was not to be.
Another ordeal even more
appalling than the first
lay before us.
Even when so much
else had failed,
we could have obtained
a prolonged peace,
lasting all our lives
at least, simply
by keeping Germany disarmed
in accordance with the treaty,
and by treating her with
justice and magnanimity.
This latter condition
was very nearly
achieved at [INAUDIBLE] in 1925.
But the failure to
enforce the disarmament
clauses, and above all to
sustain the League of Nations--
both of which purposes could
easily have been accomplished--
brought upon us the
Second World War.
Once again, the English-speaking
world gloriously but narrowly
emerged, bleeding
and breathless,
but united as we
never were before.
[APPLAUSE]
This unity is our
present salvation,
because after all
our victories, we
are now faced by perils
both grave and near,
and by problems more
dire than have ever
confronted Christian
civilization, even
in this 20th century
of storm and change.
There remains, however,
a key of deliverance.
It is the same key which
was searched for by those
who labored to set up the
World Court at the Hague
in the early years
of the century.
It is the same
conception which animated
President Wilson and his
colleagues at Versailles--
namely, the creation
of a world instrument
capable, at least, of
giving to all its members
security against aggression.
The United Nations
organization, which
has been created
under the inspiring
leadership of my great
wartime friend, President
Roosevelt, that organization--
[APPLAUSE]
--which took the place
of the former league,
has so far been
rent and distracted
by the antagonism
of Soviet Russia
and by the fundamental
schism which
was opened between communism
and the rest of mankind.
But we must not despair.
We must persevere.
And if the gulf
continues to widen,
we must make sure that
the cause of freedom
is defended by all the resources
of combined forethought
and superior science.
Here lies the best hope of
averting a third world struggle
and a sure means of coming
through it without being
enslaved or destroyed.
[APPLAUSE]
One of the questions which
you are debating here
is defined as the failure
of social and political
institutions to keep pace with
material and technical trends.
Scientists should never
underrate the deep-seated
qualities of human
nature, and how,
repressed in one direction,
they will certainly
break out in another.
The genus Homo-- if I
may display my Latin.
I have some, not much.
The genus Homo is
a tough creature
who has traveled here
by a very long road.
His nature has been
shaped and his virtues
ingrained by many millions
of years of struggle, fear,
and pain.
And its spirit has, from the
earliest dawn of history,
shown itself upon occasion
capable of mounting
to the sublime far above
material conditions
or mortal terrors.
He still remains--
man still remains--
as Pope described
him 200 years ago.
Placed on the isthmus
of this middle state,
a being darkly wise
and rudely great,
created half the rise
and half the fall,
great lord of all things,
yet a prey to all.
Sole judge of truth
in endless error
hurled the glory, jest,
and riddle of the world.
In his introductory
address, Dr. [? Bertrad, ?]
the dean of humanities,
spoke with awe
of an approaching scientific
ability to control
men's thoughts with precision.
I should be very
content personally
if my task in this world is
done before that happens.
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
Laws just or unjust may
govern men's actions.
Tyrannies may restrain
or regulate their words.
The machinery of propaganda
may pack their minds
with falsehoods
and deny them truth
for many generations of time.
But the soul of man,
thus held in a trance
nor frozen in a
long night, can be
awakened by a spark coming
from God knows where.
And in a moment,
the whole structure
of lies and oppression
is on trial for its life.
Peoples in bondage
need never despair.
Let them hope and trust
in the genius of mankind.
Science no doubt, if
sufficiently perverted,
could exterminate us all.
But it is not in the power at
present of material forces--
at present or in any period
which the youngest here tonight
need take into
practical account,
to alter permanently the
main elements in human nature
and restrict the
infinite variety of forms
in which the soul and
genius of the human race
can and will express itself.
How right you are, Dr. Compton,
in this great institution
of technical study
and achievement,
to keep a dean of
humanities and to give him
so commanding a part to
play in your discussion.
[APPLAUSE]
No technical knowledge
can outweigh knowledge
of the humanities, in the
gaining of which philosophy
and history walk hand-in-hand.
Our inheritance of
well-founded, slowly
conceived codes
of honor, morals,
and manners, the
passionate convictions,
which so many hundreds of
millions share together,
of the principles of
freedom and justice
are far more precious
to us than anything
which scientific
discoveries could bestow.
Those whose minds are
attracted or compelled
to rigid and symmetrical
systems of government
should remember that
logic, like science,
must be the servant and
not the master of man.
[APPLAUSE]
Human beings and human
societies are not
structures that are built,
or machines that are forged.
They are plants that grow
and must be tended as such.
Life is a test, and this
world a place of trial.
Always the problems-- or it
may be the same problem--
will be presented to every
generation in different forms.
The problems of victory
may even be more
baffling than those of defeat.
However much the
conditions change,
the supreme question is how
we live and grow and bloom
and die, and how far
each human life conforms
to standards, which
are not wholly related
to space or time.
And here I speak
not only to those
who enjoy the blessings
and consolation
of revealed religion,
but also to those
who face the mysteries
of human destiny alone.
I say that the flame
of Christian ethics
is still our highest guide.
To guard and cherish it
is our first interest,
both spiritually and materially.
The fulfillment of spiritual
beauty in our daily life
is vital to our survival.
Only by bringing it into
perfect application can
we hope to solve for ourselves
the problems of this world,
and not of this world alone.
Ladies and gentlemen, I cannot
speak to you here tonight
without expressing
to the United States,
as I have perhaps
some right to do,
the thanks of Britain and of
Europe for the splendid part
America is playing in the world.
We seek nothing from Russia
but goodwill and fair play.
If, however, there is
to be a war of nerves,
let us make sure that our
nerves are strong and are
fortified by the deepest
convictions of our hearts.
[APPLAUSE]
If we persevere steadfastly
together and allow
no appeasement of tyranny
and wrongdoing in any form,
it may not be our
nerve or the structure
of our civilized nation
which will break.
Something else will break, and
peace may yet be preserved.
[APPLAUSE]
Many nations have risen to
the summit of human affairs,
but here is a great example
where new-won supremacy has not
been used for
self-aggrandizement, but only
for further sacrifice.
[APPLAUSE]
Three years ago, I made a
speech at Fulton, Missouri,
under the auspices
of President Truman.
Many people here, and
in my own country,
were startled and even
shocked by what I said.
But events have
vindicated and fulfilled
in much detail the warnings
which I deemed it my duty
to give at that time.
Today, there is a very
different climate of opinion.
I'm in cordial accord with
much that is being done.
We have as dominating facts
the famous [INAUDIBLE],,
the new unity in Western Europe,
and now the Atlantic Pact.
How has this tremendous change
in our outlook and policy
been accomplished?
Let us inquire into that.
The responsible ministers in
all the countries concerned
deserve high credit.
There is credit enough for all.
In my own country, the
foreign secretary, Mr. Bevin,
who has come here tonight
to sign the Atlantic Pact,
has shown himself, like
many American public men,
above mere partisan
interest in dealing
with these national
and world issues.
[APPLAUSE]
No one could,
however, have brought
about these immense changes
in the feeling of the United
States, of Great
Britain, and of Europe,
but for the astounding policy of
the Russian Soviet government.
We may well ask, why have
they deliberately acted
for three long years so as
to unite the free world again
them?
It is certainly not
because there are not
some very able men among them.
Why, then, have they done it?
I will offer you my own answer
to this strange conundrum.
It is because they fear the
friendship of the West more
than its hostility.
They cannot-- they cannot afford
to allow free and friendly
intercourse to grow up between
the vast areas they control
and the civilization
of the West.
The Russian people must not
see what is going on outside,
and the world must
not see what goes on
inside the Soviet domain.
13 men in the
Kremlin, holding down
hundreds of millions
of people and aiming
at the rule of the world,
feel that at all costs
they must keep up the barriers.
Self-preservation-- not for
Russia, but for themselves--
lies at the root and
is the explanation
of their sinister
and malignant policy.
[APPLAUSE]
In consequence of
the Soviet conduct,
the relations of
communist Russia
with the other great
powers of the world
are without
precedent in history.
Measures and
countermeasures have
been taken on many occasions,
which in any previous period
could only have meant or
accompanied armed conflict.
The situation has
been well described
by distinguished
Americans as the Cold War.
And the question is asked,
are we winning the Cold War?
Well, this cannot be decided
by looking at Europe alone.
We must also look at Asia.
The worst disaster
since our victory
has been the collapse of
China under communist attack
and in [? creed. ?] China, in
which the United States have
always taken a high interest,
comprises an immense part
of the population of the world.
The absorption of
China and of India
into the Kremlin-controlled
communist empire
would certainly
bring measureless
bloodshed and misery to
800 or 900 million people.
On the other hand,
the position in Europe
has so far been
successfully maintained.
The prodigious effort
of the Berlin airlift
has carried us
through the winter.
Time, though dearly bought,
has been gained for peace.
The efficiency of the American
and British air forces
has been proved and improved.
Most of all, the spectacle
of the British and Americans
trying to feed the 2
million Germans in Berlin,
in their zone in Berlin,
while the Soviet government
was trying to starve them
out, has been an object lesson
to the German people,
far beyond anything
that words could convey.
I trust that small and
needless provocations
of German sentiment may be
avoided by the Western powers.
The revival and union of Europe
cannot be achieved without
the earnest and freely given
aid of the German people.
This has certainly been promoted
by the Berlin airlift, which
has fully justified itself.
Nevertheless, ladies and
gentlemen, fear and its shadows
brood over Western Europe today.
A month ago, in Brussels,
I spoke to a meeting
of 30,000 Belgians.
I could feel at once their
friendship and their anxiety.
They have no Atlantic
Ocean, no English Channel,
between them and the Russian
communist armored divisions.
Yet they bravely
and ardently support
the cause of united Europe.
I admired them.
I was also conscious
of the hope and faith
which lay, like
the Greek people,
place in the United States.
I could see the movement
of this vast crowd
when I spoke of the hands--
strong hand-- stretched
out across the ocean
by the great republic.
You have great
responsibilities there,
for much faith is
placed upon you.
I must not conceal from you
tonight the truth as I see it.
It is certain that Europe
would have been communized,
like Czechoslovakia, and
London under bombardment
some time ago, but
for the deterrent
of the atomic bomb in the
hands of the United States.
[APPLAUSE]
Another question is also asked--
is time on our side?
This, ladies and
gentlemen, is not
a question that can be answered
except within strict limits.
We have certainly not an
unlimited period of time
before a settlement
should be achieved.
The utmost vigilance
should be practiced,
but I do not think
myself that violent
or [? precipitate ?]
action should be taken now.
War is not inevitable.
The Germans have a wise
saying that trees do not
grow up to the sky.
Often something happens
to turn or mitigate
the course of events.
400 or 500 years
ago, Europe seemed
about to be conquered
by the Mongols.
Two great battles were fought
almost on the same day,
near Vienna and in Poland.
In both of these, the chivalry
and armed power of Europe
was completely shattered
by the Asiatic hordes
of mounted archers.
It seemed that
nothing could avert
the doom of the famous
continent, from which
modern civilization
and culture had
spread throughout the world.
But at a critical moment,
something happened.
The great Khan died.
The succession was vacant,
and the Mongol armies
and their leaders trooped
back on their ponies
to cross the 7,000 miles
which separated them
from their capital in order
to choose a successor.
They never returned-- till now.
[APPLAUSE]
We need not abandon
hope or patience.
Many favorable
processes are on foot.
Under the impact of communism,
all the free nations
are being welded together as
they never have been before
and never could be, but for
the harsh external pressure
to which they are
being subjected.
We have no hostility to the
Russian people and no desire
to deny them their legitimate
rights and security.
I hoped that Russia,
after the war,
would have access
to unfrozen waters,
into every ocean, guaranteed by
the world organization of which
she be a leading member.
I hoped that she would have the
freest access, which indeed she
has at the present time, to
raw materials of every kind,
and that Russians everywhere
would be received as brothers
in the human family.
That still remains
our aim and our ideal.
[APPLAUSE]
This is a hard experience
in the life of the world.
After our great victory,
which we believed
would decide the struggle for
freedom, for our time at least,
we thought we had deserved
better of fortune.
But unities and associations
are being established
by many nations throughout
the free world with a speed
and reality which would not
have been achieved perhaps
for generations.
Of all these unities, the
one most precious to me
is, to use an expression I used
first at Harvard six years ago,
the one most precious to me
is the fraternal association
between the British Commonwealth
of nations and the United
States.
[APPLAUSE]
Do not, my friends, I beg you,
underrate the enduring strength
of Britain.
As I said at Fulton, do not
suppose that half a century
from now, you will not
see 70 or 80 millions
of Britons spread
about the world
and united in defense of our
traditions, our way of life,
and the world causes
which you and we espouse.
[APPLAUSE]
United we stand secure.
Let us then move
forward together
in this charge of our
mission and our duty,
fearing God and nothing else.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "THE STAR SPANGLED
BANNER"]